[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
it's hilarious like i'll be in the
kitchen and all of a sudden i'm always
in the kitchen doing something right and
one day i just come in like what the
[ __ ] kind of toaster is this
what was wrong with the other toaster i
gotta download i need to download the
app to make [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
no sudden she'll just be like dad don't
scream like that
and the second i hear that voice i'm
like you're right buddy you're right
buddy sorry
sorry i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
download the app here
download the app and you might would
have taken just to make some stupid
talks
today is monday july 11th and tomorrow
we're getting a brand new billboard
netflix special it comes out tuesday and
it will be his fifth special this one is
called bill burr live at the red rocks
according to the laugh button bur shares
an inspirational talk for women how
doing mushrooms has changed his life
finding common ground with lesbians and
how his four-year-old has helped his
anger management so those are some of
the topics to expect in the special
again comes out tomorrow on netflix so i
think it should be out at midnight
tonight tomorrow this is obviously a
little bit different than the billburn
front special that netflix put out a few
months ago this one will get to see him
do a full hour of comedy so i have high
expectations going into tomorrow bill
burr live at the red rocks
bill burr live at red rocks i know a
little something about it i produced and
directed i had an amazing year
scouting
prepping
shooting and editing with phil who's
nothing but a pain in the ass
but
taking [ __ ] from him which is what i do
for a living is well worth it because he
is the master
and this is i think we had a lot of fun
making paper tiger don't get me wrong
but this leaves it in the dust this is i
think
bill burr at his best i can't wait for
you to see it also welcome back to joke
world and the joke world comedy update
where every monday we're bringing you
the news of the comedy world whether it
be new specials new tours who went on
each other's shows the previous week
everything you need to know about your
favorite comedians so please consider
subscribing to this channel right now to
stay in the comedy loop and downloading
this episode on spotify netflix also
posted some new dave chappelle content
this week it's a 40-minute speech that
he gave at his alma mater at his high
school the duke ellington school of arts
in washington dc they are renaming their
performing arts center after him and
this is the speech that he was giving at
that ceremony in the speech he talks
about his time attending the school and
how that impacted the rest of his career
and also how he had to leave the
chappelle show and how that was a tough
decision for him and then lastly he
covers the backlash he received after
his latest netflix special the closer
saying no matter what they say about the
closer it's still one of the most
watched specials on netflix the more you
say i can't say something the more
urgent it is for me to say it
it has nothing to do with what you're
saying i can't say it has everything to
do with my freedom of artistic
expression during the speech he
announced instead of naming the theater
after him he wants it to be called the
theater of artistic freedom and
expression we call it the theater for
artistic freedom and expression
because to me
that's what i would want for myself and
that's what i want for every student
that goes to the school
uh and i do feel like if that's
threatened
then the society at large is threatened
that if artists feel stifled then
everyone's stifled although it's not a
stand-up special it is still dave
chappelle on a stage with a microphone
so he's cracking jokes he's having a
good time there's some laughs in there
and there's some serious stuff i'd
recommend giving it a watch the guest
list is where we go through who was on
each other's shows last week to make
sure you don't miss anything that you
want to see from your favorite comedians
so starting off your mom's house did not
have a guest two bears one cave was tom
segura and ryan sickler which is always
a great duo those shows were lit awesome
yeah every show you've taken chicago was
insane we did the arena yeah the same we
did the arena in this first time ever
done in arena of course first time i've
ever done stand up in a suit also yeah
which felt
better than i thought it would then you
murdered thanks man you murdered felt
good that was fun yeah and then we went
to elenia yeah for the one of the
craziest dinners i've ever had ever and
i sat next to your mom and i got to say
something
you're my mom's favorite comedian now
outside of you for your mom because
that's normal i gotta think i might have
swayed the pendulum a little bit i might
be your mom's favorite comedian outside
of you right now here's the thing
i don't think i'm my mom's favorite
comedian
i think i might have [ __ ] reverse
rolls with you charo sat next to me and
killed us all night long my dad was a
hardcore fan
that era is over
so your mom she literally came back
from
from from that show
because she came sat we did that back to
back nights
and she came back and she goes you're a
piece of [ __ ]
andrew schultz and flagrant continued
their celebrity guest run with jake paul
whiskey ginger had on harry mack kill
tony tonight is going to be a banger
it's shane gillis and mark norman that
premieres at 9pm
joke world podcast coming out wednesday
we interviewed nemish patel and stavros
is on we might be drunk we were
literally on this block do you remember
because we were doing pod don't lie on
this block you got a call and i gotta
call it hbo pass yeah
and you're like i don't know man maybe
i'll go to youtube and you really didn't
want to and like it's turned out to be
all of you guys doing and then me doing
has turned out to be the best thing for
our careers yeah yeah and that was doing
youtube special so yeah to the people
yeah anyone even now it's like you just
have that link you're just like totally
here's a little link click and any
[ __ ] in the world can see it you know
exactly there's no blackouts it's just
you know people from [ __ ] denmark are
like this is a good special right right
that's the coolest part is you're like
literally getting messages from people
in like poland who are like
you need to come to poland you're like i
won't but i appreciate the message
isn't that the weirdest when are you
coming to bangladesh
that's not going to happen you get
messages like we got from norman i get a
ton of messages from india hell yeah
huge in india really yeah i don't know
why india but that we get a lot of you
know the first when i had a lot of
messages from india was the infancy of
my uh
instagram where i was just fully nude
and it was a bunch of it was a bunch of
horny gay indian men from india
and it turns out even the gay the gay
ones behave the same way as the straight
ones when they were like they're like
when come let me see penis
some guy literally
the first time i i learned my lesson to
never open a photo from an account i
don't follow it was straight up a
[ __ ] indian guy
the resolution on the camera it must
have been like an android from 10 years
ago yeah it's blurry it's like you know
he's in a [ __ ] house with just
exposed wires just his dick fully out
beating off in like some shack wherever
the [ __ ] he's from i was like you know
what i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna skip opening these from
now on
i'm not gonna
put a guy with pictures and he's like
dude you were asking for it yeah he
knows those poses he did frame his [ __ ]
in a way it still haunts me the like the
friend the cinematography of that
jackoff video because it was like from
underneath so his dick looked way too
big it was like like a like a like a
blimp coming into frame slowly you know
what i mean
for the stand-up specials coming out
soon we have tonight actually jeremiah
watkins and stand up on the spot that
features mark norman ari shafir giannis
pappas and the rd garbage crew that
comes out tonight and then july 17th
andrew schultz is doing his pay-per-view
special and if you missed it a month ago
nimish patel dropped thank you china
that's a hilarious hour so go check that
out if you missed it or if you've
already seen it go check it out again
and check him out on our podcast coming
up soon great interview we did today
that's it for this week in comedy make
sure you comment any podcasts or
comedians that you'd like us to cover
any comedy news that you think we missed
want to make sure we're getting all the
good information out to you guys also we
got some great videos coming down the
pipe this week try not to laugh tom
segura is coming in the next few days
that's part three so be on the lookout
for that turn on the post notifications
thank you for watching
[Music]
you